[Music]
let's go to
seattle home of the grunge
allison chains the pearl jams
even the sound gardens chris cornell
greatest singer of all time and talked
to rose what's going on rose
hi
how are you
i'm good in you
you don't sound good i'm great
i'm sitting in a
bunch of snow here in nashville how are
you you're not you're not doing okay
yeah i'm just tired all right so what's
up how can i help
well i was just wondering to what level
um you should change for a partner or
how much you should compromise
oh this is a loaded question so unpack
that for me
so
um
well my boyfriend has been telling me
that he wants me to lose weight for him
because he wants me to be
the best for him as he says it and he
he needs to in order for him to find me
more attractive he wants me to lose away
and i don't feel like i should be doing
that but then if i'm asking him to
change like
um
do things without me having to tell him
constantly or just put in a little more
effort into the relationship
i don't know if it's a double standard
asking him to change and me not changing
so a couple of things one i'm just
i'm rarely speechless rose and you made
me speechless so well done i want to
give you a high five on that
um
that's a brazen man
that will look at his
wife
are y'all married girlfriend
girlfriend girlfriend look at his
girlfriend and say
you need to be the best for me
and um you're overweight you're not
attractive fix it
it's a brazen man
brazen man
like where i'm from you get murdered
kind of man
and on the other hand you ask an
interesting question so you want him to
be more emotionally present and what
else
just be able to do things without me
constantly having to tell him to do them
so be invested in the relationship at
all
yeah okay and so
our
man you're asking a great question so
here's what first pop said oh i'm not
even gonna go there that's just i'm just
gonna muddy the waters all right so
here's here's the way i think you can
think about this
if somebody let's say my wife let's say
my wife came to me and said hey i need
you to lose weight
and i would say why and she'd say well
i've known you for 25 years and when you
get to be this size whether it's because
you know you're not working out or
you're not eating right or you're
lifting a lot you just get big i snore
or my sleep score goes down or i get a
little grumpy or i'm always she'll
notice things like i say oh my knees or
my back or whatever my neck hurts
whatever
and she'll say hey it's time you need to
get back on a plan
and she's not saying that because
she has suddenly found me unattractive
which is really hard because i'm a smoke
show let's be honest
she's saying
for your health and well-being i love
you and care about you so much i want
you to be your best self
and you've given me permission to speak
into your life and i see patterns
because i've known you for 25 years
one of your patterns is xyz abc
i think it's time
that's different than
i don't think you're pretty and i
deserve pretty so fix it
do you see how those are the same thing
but different
yeah okay
so one of these is i want you to lose
weight because i want you to feel better
i don't not i want you to be the best
for me but i want you to be the best for
you i want you to feel good
and that's different than i need you to
be hotter
and so
the differences with what you're saying
i love your question
but here's where it's different
let's look at you and let's look at him
and then let's make a triangle with the
relationship okay so you have the
relationship that's separate from both
of y'all
when you get married you both agree that
we are now becoming a single unit
we are becoming this new thing together
we're fusing together
and this gets lost in all of our
cultural talk of marriage
everybody's screwed this thing up when
you're in you're in
and when you do that you say what is the
things that are going to better serve
this relationship
he is saying you be hot not for the
relationship but for me
you are saying
hey would you engage into this
relationship
for us
so this whole unit operates seamlessly
together with one do you see what i'm
saying
yeah the spirit there is so so different
and so i get that yes you're asking him
to change he's asking you to change but
you all are coming at it for two very
different reasons one is incredibly
selfish and demeaning
and the other
is
trying to find common connection
how do we build an ecosystem where we're
both loved and we're both in this thing
does that make sense
yeah it does
how long have you been with this guy
a little over two years
when did this kind of talk start
um i would say about
six to eight months
into the relationship or six or eight
months ago
uh ago
have you become unhealthy during the
pandemic
no i'm the exact same way i was um when
we met
so what else is going on beneath these
two stories
your relationship is on the rocks what
else is going on
i just feel like i'm not good enough
well he tells you that you know what i
mean
yeah
that's why you feel that way because you
got somebody that says they love you and
then they tell you you're not good
enough for me
it's just confusing because
he says he
wants to be with me but
i don't understand
i i tell him it's not
you don't want to be with me you want to
be with a different version of me
and i just
don't know
what to do hold on can i say something
hard rose
yeah
you do know what to do
you also know that it's gonna hurt like
bloody hell right
you do exactly know what you what to do
i'm heartbroken for you
you can never do something sustainable
over time for somebody else you got to
do it for you
yeah
and if you need to lose weight that's a
whole other call
but do it for you
because you want to feel good and you
want to live a long
fun
adventurous life
and when you're 65 you want to roll
around on the ground with your green
kids
you don't want to be tied up to tubes
and machines and pills your whole adult
life
and you want to feel good in whatever
you want to wear i mean there's a
hundred
million reasons why you lose weight
for you
but you don't do it for to please
somebody else because you know why that
kind of pleasing is about power that
kind of pleasing is going to move so
let's say you lost 100 pounds it would
move on to something else
you need to be this way in bed you need
to start doing this you need to actually
start doing that
it will just move
because it's not about this one thing
do you have what's something you you
want to change what's something you want
to get better at this year 2022 not what
somebody's told you what's something you
want to grow towards
um
get better at my job what's your job
i work in construction okay are you a
baller dude
away i bet you're a boss baller huh what
do you do in construction
um i just started so i just my goal is
just to become more confident
um what do you do out on the site
um
i work with concrete
so i pour concrete slab
yes dude i told you you're a gangster
man
so
are you going to get better this year
how are you going to get better
um
work more and i just need to be more
confident and standing up for what i
know
i should be doing
so yeah confidence comes from when you
when you are able to
we we live in a culture that says you
just need to be confident no dude our
bodies know and we're not telling the
truth i can get up in front of a bunch
of people and say i'm going to dive off
this high dive and do a triple double
flip i just need to be confident my body
knows we're about to splat
confidence comes from
a series of little and increasingly
bigger wins
i'm confident enough i played that whole
song in my basement now i'm confident
enough to play it in front of my kids
and then i'm confident enough to play it
at practice and now i'm confident to
play that song on stage
and you're exactly right work more i
wish there was another way around it but
you're exactly right you got to practice
concrete work over and over and you're
gonna screw stuff up and people are
gonna go like what are you doing no
girls allowed and you're gonna be like
i'm freaking rose the concrete sorcerer
and you're gonna i don't even know if
that's a thing is there something that's
a concrete sorcerer probably not but
you're gonna crush it
and can i tell you something that kind
of breaks my heart and kind of fills my
heart at the same time
what i want you to go back and listen to
this audio when the show comes out
talking about this guy
who has beat you down
and told you that you're not good enough
for him
your voice has a particular tone a
weight to it a heft to it a sadness to
it
and when you started talking about
concrete work you cheered up
you've got joy in your heart about that
and that's awesome
that's awesome
you are worth being loved rose do you
believe that
i'm trying to
i'm not i never lie to somebody on the
show
never gonna lie to you you are worth
being loved
you're also worth feeling good you're
also worth having great physical health
okay
but you're worth being loved for you
now if he comes to you and says hey i
was complete idiot
i said this wrong i screwed up i don't
know what's going on
covet mess got me nuts i've been locked
down for two years here in in seattle
like listen i'm sorry
i want you to
feel so good
and our relationship will grow
if i feel good if you feel good if we're
both working towards goals that we both
that's a whole different conversation
about weight
right
yeah
so
i'm not gonna make you say it out loud
on this on the radio
you've got a series of hard choices
ahead of you right
yeah do you all live together
we do okay
you got a hard series of of decisions to
make
do you have a girlfriend that you can
sit down and talk to that walks
alongside you through this
yeah i do good
what do they tell you
basically the same thing
you know why
because i love you
because you're worth being well
and you're worth being loved
okay
yeah
i'm grateful for you rose i know this is
a hard call